there was a movie we had out this summer
called Captain America Civil War good he
the characters in that movie you know
some of them going to other movies some
of them have come from other movies one
of them was introduced for very first
time in that movie
his name was black panther
he's going to star in a standalone movie
we don't start filming that movie until
January and frankly I don't want you
have to hear me talk about it much
longer
ladies and gentlemen the director of
Black Panther Brian Kuebler
what's going on Haleh listen this is a
really really emotional for me been on I
don't know if you guys noticed I'm a big
big comic book fan in 2009 I was my
first Comic Con i sat way way way way
back here so it's so it's absolutely
crazy to be looking at my people from
this view you know I mean you're very
crazy hard on the script right now it's
really early and beginning to be getting
ready so happy to be here that Kevin let
us let us come out the co-writer Joe
Robert Cole and myself do trying to make
something that you guys really enjoy
about the world of a condom but we all
know what's the coolest part of all the
word of a condom that's the fact they
have a king a warrior king that takes
care of that protection and I'll be
fortunate enough to have an incredible
actor portraying I can and he's here
right now
it's a lot I can say over over the past
couple of months after the movie has
come out the glimpse into the character
and interval Conda has been a beautiful
beautiful thing for me thank you for
everything that I've heard from the fans
about the character at about what you
hope to see in black panther
I cannot wait to a mass pour of it for
you all right and Ryan Nets has some
beautiful things in store for us I
remember I ran into you a couple of days
after the Civil War premiere and I was
like oh my god blood pair was amazing
there gonna be a Black Panther movie and
you're like no I'll say well you know
they won't allow me to say I know so
just from from there to here on stage at
Hall age it's now out in the open I mean
I know you guys haven't started really
doing anything yet but now that everyone
knows and you can present in front of
7,000 people and what does that
experience feel like big big here at
Comic Con is my first time here right
I can literally feel incorporating
inside it's our core it is amazing it is
amazing thank you so much for just
giving giving back what we give to you
it's incredible and right I think I
think some other friends came along too
oh you might have a couple other than
she um one of the one of the really
amazing things about a Volvo Kannada is
they have they have these these these
women who are incredibly for the best
where the best fighters in the kingdom
we might have brought might have brought
one of them along if the character Nakia
who's played by the incredible loop it's
annyeong
we got a adversary if I have to have
this face named Erik kill monger flag by
Michael B Jordan
thank you thank you
and last but definitely not least the
head of the Durham Elijah a character
named or coy yet I can't wait for you
guys to meet played by the amazing
actress Danai gurira
I saw you yesterday okay thank you I
just I feel bad helping people cuz I got
the comic-con sweat on me so I don't
want to get too sweaty on people but I
thank you so much I appreciate that
so what can you I know you guys haven't
really start anything in I know you have
to get back in and start shooting but is
there anything you can tell us how do
you guys feel about joining this amazing
experience and cast and working with
Ryan I'm extremely excited to be a part
of this cast we're going to access the
director again credit cast and a new
world and a new character kind of sets
up to portray so I'm extremely excited I
wish I could tell you guys more I don't
even know Ryan's been keeping it under
wraps pretty pretty pretty good so next
time hopefully we'll have a lot more say
and repeat ad do you have anything you
know anything you're excited about about
taking on a role like this and getting
into the Sahara University well first of
all it's my first time at Comic Con -
Wow thank you for the very warm welcome
I'm looking forward to kicking some ass
and tonigh you're going from from an
iconic television thing to an iconic
film thing how does that transition feel
for you yeah it's not my first time ago
not my first time in college I love you
all I'm still pinching myself I cannot
believe I'm up here with these
astounding people I just finished
working this beautiful woman that
amazing that over there this filmmaker
is I've respected and admired for so
long as well as these two astounding
actors so to sit down with mr. Kugler
and learn his vision has been I'm just
utterly pinching myself to see this come
to life and to be a part of it I still
kind of can't believe I'm standing here
so I'm kind of you know I mean that
inarticulate place but yeah you can
bring katana cuz you know how to you
know how to wield the katana yeah I'm
gonna learn some new tricks well I know
you guys I know you guys there's nothing
really to show they haven't started yet
I know you guys have to go we have that
but thank you so much for being around
is there anything you want to say before
you before we leave just just just want
to thank you guys all y'all energy man
we're gonna take it in go and go work
hard see you guys soon black panther
you
you